now a new report has detailed
allegations of bullying harassment and
discrimination in every fire and rescue
service in England a quarter of services
inspectors found examples of racist
homophobic and misogynistic Behavior
with the behavior often excused as
banter
well I'm joined Now by Roy wilshere of
his Majesty's inspector of Fire and
Rescue Services who carried out this
report so thanks so much for coming in
to tell us about it there was an
independent review Into the London fire
brigade last year which Unearthed some
pretty unacceptable Behavior you seem to
have found that that's the case across
our fire services
yes so as you've just said we've had uh
cases of bullying harassment and
discrimination reported in every fire
and rescue service in England and we
found evidence of racism sexism
homophobia and at least a quarter of
those Services what our links to
something that's really important is
trust so firefighters can do a very
difficult job they need to be able to
trust their colleagues to carry out
their job but all too often that was
that trust was undermined by geography
Behavior or things called banter that
weren't really banter and that led to
people not wanting to call these
behaviors out both you know people staff
and Senior officers and thinking
sometimes that if they reported this
Behavior they'd be ostracized or
vilified or their careers might be
shortened and finally we found there was
no standard for background checks for
people joining the fire service some
services do that well many don't and we
think there should be a standard of
background checks for everyone how
shocked were you at what you found I
personally I was very short some of the
things we uncovered were appalling and
appalling behaviors I thought these were
things you know decades past in the past
to still find them now you know in the
21st century 2020 to 23 as we have it is
truly shocking and we don't want to
offend our viewers but give us some idea
of what some of the most shocking
instances you found certainly some of
the ones we found so uh yeah a senior
officer using a racist term to refer to
a black colleague and just laugh net off
as as banter two male firefighters
they're joking if you can joke about
these things about raping a female
firefighter then acting that out
homophobic graffiti on someone's Locker
you know truly appalling that's why our
recommendations are so important there
and I will come on to those but but do
you think it's possible that there are
predators in the fire service as we've
seen exist in the police I did I can't
guarantee there isn't I'd like to think
there isn't but we can't guarantee that
at the moment because of those
background checks and those other
recommendations we're talking about so
how safe would you say it is for women
and for minorities to work in far
service at the moment
well things need to improve undoubtedly
but I would still encourage people to
join the fire service it's still a
fantastic career for people and there
are thousands of men and women in the
fire service still doing an excellent
job great places to work but these
behaviors we found are happening far too
often than they need to stop and as
recommendations you've also highlighted
the fact that people didn't feel
comfortable about reporting some of this
Behavior so let's explore what's gone
wrong I mean does it go wrong at the
very beginning what's vetting like for
example for people joining the fire
service is it adequate so as we say for
the the fire service you know veterans
very much pleasing is a common thing but
background checks so the DBS people
might have heard about so that's
background checks and the barring
service there's no standard for that so
Fire Rescue Services don't actually have
to do that so we're saying there should
be as a minimum fire service including
in the rehabilitation of Offenders Act
and then looking further and that should
be for everyone joining the service and
they should have appropriate background
checks for the job they're doing and
what about this issue of speaking out
are leaders in the fire services to
blame for the culture at least of them
not being able to to report or feel they
couldn't report bad behavior it's
unfortunately some leaders are and I
think leadership goes throughout the
service so we're not just talking about
the chief officers and that level but
leadership starts on the fire station
and other teams so in some cases leaders
are to blame and we saw some evidence of
leaders saying to people if they if you
report something it will be investigated
by my friends or you know your career
will be ended or if you're on a station
and want to report you'll be ostracized
from the station so we think there
should be a safe and confidential line
and it's one of our major
recommendations where people can report
whistleblow if you like and get these
things centered and what do you think
should happen to those people who have
been engaged in this kind of behavior
well ultimately and that's a decision
for the employers and the Chief Fire
officers but if some people who lose
their jobs over there then so be it we
need to clean up the fire rescue service
and do my 35 recommendations in all so
what's your message to the government
this morning well we've been talking to
the government closely so when we make
these recommendations we talk to the
people we make recommendations to so the
government National providers Council
fire Standards Board we know they're
accepting these recommendations but I
think these things need to move quickly
now it's time for this Behavior to stop
well yes and and how difficult will that
be I mean clearly you have a path that
you think needs to be taken to change
things but how difficult is it how
ingrained is this kind of behavior in
the culture of our fire Services yeah so
cultural change in any organization is
always difficult culture is the way we
do things around here but I need to
reiterate it's not every service and
it's certainly not every fire station so
things can change or we've got
recommendations about how to carry out
misconduct investigations how to do
background checks how to give better
training to the leaders and how people
can report to these instances and feel
safe doing so so I think they can make a
significant change what do you think
this does to public Trust
well yeah the public will be shocked as
I was some of these behaviors are
appalling but one thing I would like to
reiterate if you need the fire service
still don't 999 they will attend and
they will help you
and uh what's your message then to fire
officers up and down the country who've
been on the receiving end of some of
this inappropriate and offensive uh
Behavior what would you say to them well
first of all they they um they don't
want my sympathy but they have my
support I I understand what it must feel
like if they don't feel supported at
work people should be able to go to work
with dignity and respect and feel safe
and be able to trust their colleagues so
we understand that's why we've made
these recommendations and that's why
we're calling on all those organizations
I mentioned to implement these
recommendations without delay okay well
Roy it will show we really appreciate
you coming in to tell us about this and
thanks very much indeed thank you